your favorite joke from Transformers
rise of the beasts almost didn't make
the cut Pete Davidson's ripping was so
controversial that the director had to
fight to keep it in and Anthony Ramos
insisted on doing all his own stunts
even when that meant being thrown 30
feet in the air repeatedly you aren't
gonna believe some of the things this
cast went through Anthony definitely
deserves his 2.5 million salary from the
film it's about to be epic as we touched
on before he insisted on doing
everything in this movie for real and
since his character was supposed to keep
his cool in a crisis my character Noah's
ex-military that usually means that
Anthony was put right in the middle of
the action at least beat Davidson got to
stay safe and tucked away in a sound
booth there was this one stunt where
Anthony was getting thrown 30 feet in
the air then I'd land and get thrown
again and this went on for days
according to him they had to add extra
shooting game days because I wanted to
do it all myself and not use a double
and stunt doubles weren't the only
luxury Anthony had to do without instead
of using green screens most of the movie
was actually shot on location in Machu
Picchu the heat was crazy but some some
of the most beautiful shots you'll ever
see Anthony was a big fan of the way
that director Stephen cable Jr
approached filming while they were there
but the two of them bonded on more than
that both Stephen and Anthony grew up
listening to 90s hip-hop and Anthony was
touched to see how much of the movie's
soundtrack included music that was a
huge part of my childhood Pete Davidson
may not have had to do any stunts but
that doesn't mean his time onset was
easy to play the rebellious jokester
Autobot Mirage Pete spent a lot of time
riffing in front of a microphone
[Music]
there you go now we're friends his
improv would often leave Steve rolling
on the floor with laughter but as we
mentioned before the studio didn't have
quite as much trust in the former SNL
star there was this one joke that Pete
came up with off the cuff that was so
dirty they wanted it cut good things
Steven had his back he screened the
movie with the joke captain and that
line got the loudest laugh in the
theater this was the moment that
everybody realized we gotta keep it now
we're glad to hear that Steven was
willing to give Pete so much freedom to
do what he does best he was even willing
to change some of mirage's Animation to
fit with Pete's improv which as Steven
pointed out can be very expensive to do
but it was worth it when you see his
performance fortunately they didn't have
to do any reshoots with any of the
live-action actors because of this which
is probably for the best when you
consider how much more expensive it
would have been to get Dominique
Fishback to Peru the most incredible
thing happened to Dominique while she
was filming in Peru so for a bit of
backstory and during the ceremony a
butterfly and I'm very connected to
butterflies remind me of my grandmother
and upon arriving in Peru they had a
shaman bless the set for being on sacred
land during the ceremony a butterfly
landed in the middle of the circle and
it stayed there the entire time
afterwards Dominique laid on the grass
with the butterfly and it almost felt
like she was communicating with it this
was such a special moment for Dominique
it almost makes up for all the
terrifying stunts she had to do
afterwards there was even a few times
where certain stunts went wrong like the
time that Dominique fell from a cliff
good thing she had a harness and a guy
to catch her but not everyone was so
lucky at one point Dominique was
supposed to stop Anthony from falling
backwards and he slipped through her
fingers and fell she says it wasn't a
high fall but a fall nonetheless but
even when you have a harness on
Dominique says they're very
uncomfortable still she wanted to do as
many of her own stunts as she could to
really earn that 1.5 million salary
she's as much of a superhero as Liza
koshy Dominique said the whole extra
experience was fun but a lot of work too
but if you want all that fun without the
work all you have to do is click that
subscribe button this is a new chapter
in Liza's life she provides the
voiceover for autobot RC and Liza really
needed to channel the strength of such a
fearsome motorcycle are you a fan of
cycling Liza took it up for the role
using a stationary bike and she's truly
fallen in love with it as she put it I
started working out for this role so I
could feel as powerful as her in the
booth now you gotta appreciate that
commitment on top of that Liza would
also show up to work wearing full
athleisure I wore tight leggings just to
feel more of a stance so I wore spandex
to be more of a superhero it didn't
necessarily matter what she wore since
like Pete Davidson and Peter Dinklage
Liza spent all her time inside a
recording booth she was bringing home
that 300 000 salary either way but she
still put on a full costume because she
found that it helped me reach the power
versus wearing something that was a
little more lackadaisical loose and this
new sense of power is something Liza is
going to take with her from now on she
says to play this strong voice is a
metaphor of where I'm at in my Womanhood
you can really see why Liza says she's
in her strong Arrow right now now Peter
Dinklage didn't enjoy the sound booth
experience as much as Liza did he found
that being separated from all the action
on set you feel a bit removed from the
experience now he's done voiceover work
before and so he definitely had more
experience than Toby and wigwe was
bringing to the table but most of
Peter's previous voiceover roles were
for an animated Kids film and he found
that having had most of the movie
already filmed before he even got there
was very strange fortunately he had the
ever supportive Stephen to lean on
Stephen our incredible director just
guided me through the whole way and even
if Peter would have preferred to be on
location in Peru alongside Anthony and
Dominique he still loves that he gets to
play a villain villains are in my
experience the most fun you can have at
the movies Steven helped him not only by
getting him more involved with the plot
and characters but by encouraging him to
really have fun with the voice yeah I
mean if you want
low and creepy and growly I'm your guy
Peter loved being able to sound so
threatening and scary probably as much
as he enjoyed taking home that four
hundred thousand dollar paycheck you may
know Toby for his music but he's
breaking into the world of acting now
Transformers rise of the beasts is
Toby's very first acting role and he
apparently impressed Stephen so much
they told me Hey listen we want to add
you to some more scenes so I had to
cancel my whole European tour Toby had
been recommended for the role by a
friend who had passed on
tried to reach out
Toby thought the whole thing was a joke
it's not like he's someone like Peter
Cullen who would have been expecting an
email from Steven but when Toby found
out it was real that he decided to take
a shot but according to him because I'd
never done no acting ever in my life I
just had the script right here and just
read it like I was acting and just
recorded myself he sent the video into
the studio and movie history was made at
first Toby was a little hesitant to take
on the role because I can't be apart
from My Wife and Kids for a whole month
but the studio loved him too much to let
him go they agreed to fly out him and
his entire family just to have him
appear in this role and for a seven
hundred thousand dollar salary can you
imagine it was definitely worth it
you're definitely familiar with Peter
Cullen even if you don't know his name
he's been the voice of Optimus Prime
since all the way back in 1984. and he's
returning yet again for Rise of the
beasts and this movie has the same
ingredients that were there at the
beginning he's bringing home 500 000 for
this picture but he definitely
recognized is how far Steven is going to
pay respects to the original material
which definitely makes sense considering
Steven grew up watching The Animated
Transformers Beast Wars series but that
being said playing the same character
for almost 40 years now has gotten Peter
feeling pretty nostalgic and he's taking
this time to look back on the advice he
was given all the way back at the
beginning when Peter voiced Optimus for
the first time I was living with my
brother Larry he was a marine he told
his brother that he was auditioning to
play a truck and he started to laugh he
said he said a truck Peter had to
explain that Optimus Prime is a hero
which changed his brother's mind
completely he said Peter if you're gonna
be a leader be strong enough to be
gentle now Peter took this
my name is Optimus Prime from the planet
Cybertron and change the face of the
franchise forever so whether they were
dangling from a bridge or performing for
the very first time you can see just how
much this cast had to go through which
one of these behind the scenes details
were you the most surprised by and do
you have any thoughts on the rise of the
beasts movie now we'd love to hear what
you think so don't forget to let us know
down in the comment section